well I have I have to go to this one
because Hands Clean I've actually
covered that on this I know right I know
I know don't I get that gasp um but it
it's the things you talk about they're
just so poignant they're so like people
they don't know how to word it and you
have this very amazing way of saying
what we really want to say or we don't
know how to identify it or and and hands
clean I mean that's a really rough song
like what is that from like childhood
trauma and on MH God young there's a lot
in those lyrics yes and I and when I
first wrote it I remember the record
company having said let's do this video
where it's a karaokey and there's kids
and it's joy and I asked them I said
have you heard the
song and they said yeah it's great I was
like okay so you haven't heard the song
All right so it just felt like this you
know in in congruent kind of thing but
it actually was a lovely way to present
a song that otherwise might not have
even been listened to I think absolutely
that's what saying you have this very
catchy way but bringing your like
Webster dictionary words like I'm like I
do you know that this is not a lie I
bought my first dictionary because of
you didn't know what I was talking about
I was like I don't know how old I was
very young and I was like what are these
words I they mean something and I just
need to look them up and I literally you
the reason why I own a dictionary for
the very first time but you you are
you're such a great teacher in that and
and you're very clever at putting it in
such pop like rock like element to where
people it's catchy enough in the pop way
but it's rocking alternative and raw
enough that it's like cool and Indie
like it's like that's I don't think
anybody's ever
done yeah yeah I don't think and and
since then like you're just a
combination of love for the
entertainment and the presentation and
the performance which I live for yeah
and then I also live for the not
precious dirty dirty birdie just go for
it and don't worry about it don't censor
so a nice combination is my fantasy I
love that it's un censored
[Music]
[Applause]
a thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home